welcome to this video coverage for round
six of them joshimath memorial a sham
Kia other badge on yeah this is the
first round after the rest day and the
first round of the second turn so we
will have sort of them the let's say the
revenge games so players meter for the
second time now yeah the big question of
this round of course also how will the
world champion recover from two losses
in a row mungus Carlson had lost their
back-to-back games against him from ya
know karana and team or a job of both um
yeah somewhat uninspired games I know
it's hard to talk to attach something to
that how to describe the games but he
really didn't have his best of best of
days um okay so for this round I'm again
choosing the game by Carlton here
playing black against mamedyarov um in a
way I feel a bit sorry that I had I do
those care to his games all the time the
fifth time out of six games but um
really i thought that the game some of
the world champion were the most
interesting in those wrongs where I ever
had shows them yet today the two other
games that are not going to cover both
are drawers um we have a job of playing
white against kayaking the job of chose
very very young let's say solid opening
with the juco piano the Italian game and
it looked like that k Aachen had to
equalize comfortably but then in then he
played a somewhat weird transfer
position to a rook endgame where he
looked to be in a bit of trouble I mean
at least he needed to be precise being a
porn down at the end he managed to
secure the draw
other game or the not going to covers
corona as white played to knock em were
like I was surprised kawana by playing
the open Spanish the opener Lopez not a
very popular opening line but it's not
bad at all just a bit forgotten and I
camera got a draw at the end it for wide
it looked like be tricky for him but at
the end the draw was agreed pretty fair
result I think both of the other games
were interesting but still the most
important game of the tournament is so
the tournament of this round is the one
that I'm going to cover here and how it
does cows react to having lost two games
in a row yeah Mammadyarov he's on minus
one before that game and certainly wants
a win itself with white let's see what
happens got in Demoiselle and Madero had
played f3 before but this time is going
for Quincy to probably a wise choice in
a way because f3 is the move that
Carlton had faced them so many times
recently he added in the world
championship match against vishy anand
they play d5 he had it against um
nakamura in the Zurich tournament where
he was basically lost after he had
chosen this line I mean he's not lost
here on new fire but this lists the line
that that he played down and in this
tournament he played black against
coyoacán and there we had to had this on
the board well he got a pretty good
position really so lots of lines that
Carlton has played and well Mammadyarov
is not going to test this again what
what for the next line that gathers
coming up with his plane Quincy too yeah
no longer to play d 5 that's an
interesting choice his normal preference
after Queen c2 is
if i'm not mistaken to play castles but
okay many lights possible d5 is one of
them in some way d 5 is also related to
castles because for example if white
plays 83 this didn't happen in the game
but Chad in this particular position
like can besides playing one of the
Euler lines with 94 for example oops
this is the wrong button this was played
actually yeah what I was trying to say
is that besides one of those old
Alliance you can also play castles which
would transpose to another move order
starting with castles here this one jack
the interesting fact is that this
position is some at the moment
theoretically very solid for black there
is absolutely nothing that white has
here at the moment on the other hand
after castles there are some
alternatives along the way which is e 4
for example on 9003 and if black starts
with d5 his rationale is that a 3 my
transpose okay or white can play cd5
this is another possibility until black
as a choice can play e takes d5 or queen
d5 even and both are interesting lines
so in a way those lines are related but
none of that happened as Mammadyarov
after d5 surprisingly played the move
Knight f3 and this is some almost
unknown in this position I mean unknown
is wrong it's it's it's perfectly
normal-looking but it's not a move that
is normally played on him on a serious
level you get the odd game here and
there that that you find in the database
but it's still not a very popular move
this is a position that sometimes arises
from an entirely different move order I
just want to show you oops this is the
regals in variation of the Queens gambit
and here Quincy to would transpose to
our our game effect this happened
considerably more often than the other
move order still not usually not play
pass by stronger players so a very
curious decision and the reason why it
is a bit obscure SMS of course shown by
accounts immediately he just took on c4
the problem is that YTM has almost no
opportunity to to to get the pawn back
that's after he played Bishop g5 but
let's say III this would be an
alternative Black is playing b5 using
this pin here and this is in essence an
extra porn forum for not much really
it's some very very questionable if
White has any compensation him in fact I
think what Mammadyarov plate is one of
the better tries to get compensation
efore is also possible we form b5 a form
c6 this also has seen from time to time
mostly from from from different move
orders the problem in a way is that in
this gambit style play that you see from
time to time in the Slav and related
lines with a form b5 this kind of this
kind of moves the queen is very early
committed to see 2 a.m. and it's not so
clear that the Queen really belongs to
them if you think of the Queen being on
d1 and white having played some other
useful move the Queen from d1 has some
additional option that can sometimes
switch over to the Kings side which from
pnc to is of course not possible so this
is really a bit of an obscure line that
yaro of chose iam he played Bishop g5
and all after a while of thinking maybe
he just confused some new order not not
quite sure because it does not seem like
he had prepared this specifically and if
we now look b5 a form c6 g3 yeah this is
one way to to develop instead of course
there also was he fought as mentioned
before this type of setup is a
possibility it's an interesting and way
to assess the position if you compare it
to to some other lines that look a bit
similar one of them could be the Moscow
variation of the semi Slav or the other
would winning variation and in all of
those it could be exactly like that but
why does never play Quincy to or he only
plays them to like Quincy to if black
has already weakened himself on the King
side which also has not happened here
yeah I think g3 is somewhat Mammadyarov
plate is quite a decent way to try to
get compensation as the bishop will be
quite ok on the non-diagonal zone the
next couple of moves seem very logical
yeah queen bee six going out of the pin
makes lots of sense efore played 86 yeah
supporting the Queen side especially b5
look D 1 and here contemplate the move
h6 this is maybe maybe debatable if this
is really necessary I think you wanted
to make sure that the bishop is
retreating from from g5 h6 can be a
useful move very often it will be a
useful move but it can also be weakness
after Bishop e3 plate castles yeah and
here we come to an absolutely key
position in this game where the
yeah upcoming proceedings really i
initiated here white has to make a
choice what is he going to do in the
center and on the King side on the
queenside he is he's lost this pawn and
it's not apparent how he can get the
porn back really very often in the
Queens gambit or the Catalan which this
some of course slightly resembles you
will get the pawn back in some way due
to your pressure on the queenside this
is not going to happen here why it's
compensation here is a bit fishy anyway
but if he is going for some concrete
compensation it will be in the center on
the King side and yeah what what kinds
of moves this wide have it's it's tough
to imagine as some sort of strengthening
move here you have got everything
developed you need to do something
concrete mostly and in the center so
what moves are there he played the move
let's start with that the move d5 looks
a very yeah logical in a way opening up
the center so trying to make use that of
the fact that the rook is already on d1
and opening up your bishop what other
moves are them and other moves to
consider could be 95 this i found
interesting but their c5 as possible and
like is liberating as bishop it's not
clear what white is doing now there is
also the idea to just take on d phone on
the right moment something like that
it's just very good for black no
problems whatsoever and you have this
pawn I mean this is a really a problem
why does this pawn down and you need to
show something for it if you are doing
yeah if your shuffle around black will
play c5 at one point and if he manages
to get rid of the double porn it
activates the b7 be sure
like would be excellent um in fact in
this position the the computer this case
here Houdini points out a very
interesting possibility that I was quite
surprised surprised about um I wanted to
to look at the line e5 and i actually
had entered those moves as it is a
fairly typical way to try to play
sometimes get the night to d5 and then
avoid avoiding the trade to maybe get
get to g5 somewhere I immediately saw
that this is not really a really doing
much like it's an excellent champion but
then the computer gave the really
amazing move in this position after 95
it gave the amazing move um Bishop takes
h6 which looks totally crazy at first
but is in fact really could move it's a
it's really am it's really strange yeah
okay black black will take it I guess
and then the move Queen to d2 and the
amazing thing is h6 is hanging and there
is also the idea to take on d5 attacking
be four and attacking the Queen so if
black is playing a move to cover it
white can actually take here and get the
piece back that's really amazing with
quite good play for white even so um
yeah black will probably take on c3 here
let's say Knight takes yeah and then
white can recapture I can even play
Queen age six and this is going to end
in a draw funny enough because the King
on g8 is some in so much danger that it
will be a perpetual check there is no
way to avoid it something like that and
now maybe f6 at watches is forced to
check to give this perpetual that's
really amazing Bishop h6 is really a
strike out of the blue and this makes a
five and interesting really because look
at this what is black is supposed to do
if you if not
five is leading to yeah let's say you
draw it's pretty much false draw on what
is black going to do well you don't
really want to go back this this looks
weird due to that and maybe there are
other ideas you know there is an IG form
if you want to sort of keep it
complicated yeah and what happens now
you know what is probably playing Bishop
to f4 you cannot really allow the
capture and the night DJ Bishop d2 is
not a good idea because of c5 and white
white salt centers is crumbling down
visually forces madam y and after that
there there are many crazy complications
that might arise after c5 very difficult
to to judge really after the capture him
for example black can think about Bishop
takes e5 giving up the night on the Sun
group d 79 f 2 and there are all kinds
of discoveries reten now this is just
very very unclear it's a king here and
Bishop c6 for example yeah impossible
impossible to really judge this black
it's got two pawns for the peace and but
excellent excellent activity great
bishops the night will lend on d3 very
interesting position just one
possibility black can also take with the
northern night on c5 this can get very
very tricky as well after h3 you notice
that this is trapped but black can play
g5 here I know it looks weird but it's
possible y term does not really have a
good retreat if you go here for example
there is this mesh and black wins
instantly or here get this one coming
now there is this threat with Bishop c5
yeah like that and black just wins yeah
many crazy possibilities if I've was
interesting I mean I just I just think
that this maybe I didn't cross mama de
armas mind it's such a wacky move and by
the way black theoretically speaking
after this could try to play for wind by
not taking on h6 but this is really a
very human way to think um yeah if I've
was interesting certainly okay he went
to d5 which was answered by C five
pretty much the only move and now a five
was played this was obviously mama drose
idea pushing the a porn now to attack
the Queen and yeah one point is that
Bishop takes 85 is playable but leads to
very very murky positions and this was
obviously rejected by cards and he
didn't take yeah what is why it smooth
actually taking only six it's the point
after that if black takes on c3 is the
most interesting after this right at
least can play for a draw with e five
the idea being that now if the night
moves let's say I'm yeah we're d5 is the
most logical place certainly then there
is Bishop h6 yeah and this is check
check this even when she writes who can
can go here actually yeah this is even
winning so after Bishop h6 black cannot
really take he needs to do something
else and this is really not what black
ones I mean who is going to allow that
so the best after d takes c6 is Bishop
takes you three and after that ed
I'm sorry what takes you so it takes
here Bishop back and then I move like
night h4 for example let's do a really
unclear plane yeah something something
like that for example and now we had
moved my group d 5 covers the night and
somewhat computer ish line of course um
what I'm getting at is black could have
taken on a 5 but it leads to very murky
play and then cousin decided to just
drop back with the Queen and I think
this is this is really a good move there
also was Queen a 7 which wasn't totally
crazy but I think he just wanted to get
the Queen near the King to lend some
support very often it's really the case
that the dangerous a text that you
suffer from come from the aquine being
misplaced after Queen a 7 for example
white can try it the very crude move
Quincy one intending to just sacrifice
on age six and this can be very very
dangerous I mean for example if black
takes bishop age six this is at least a
draw if black takes now and it can
easily happen that you're getting
checkmated here with your queen on a
seven being really am awfully positioned
so he wanted to go back near the King
add this thing is just the better move
from just about angles okay now why took
on e 6f take C and night h4 very
interesting way to play looking at the
weakened g6 square
lines like that um other reasons why I
said that this age 6 move somewhat
earlier I'm just jumping back a moment
needs to be very carefully considered as
it can be yeah the the point where a
sacrifice might happen on age six and it
also can weaken the structure like here
g6 this weekend and not a big deal in
the correct and then the concrete
position but something to always some
consider if you move upon in front of
your king it very often would be a
weakening move okay cosmonaut took on c3
but just I think a pretty yeah pretty a
good decision why'd I think um could at
some point maybe intend to play the
night back from c3 and it's not so clear
what the bishop one before is doing then
okay you can argue that you can always
take at some point getting it back and
so on but if the queen is going to help
on the Kings side this is also not
happening so I think this is a good way
to play just take it and queenie eight
this is a good and very human decision
the queen is covering the sensitive
square on g6 so that the night cannot
invade and it just set up some pretty
solid defensive formation black is still
upon up I mean it's I think clear that
white has some compensation for the porn
it's not like a pawn down for nothing
but the whole the whole way the the game
develops now is some that white needs to
be very precise with his attacking moves
but black cam needs to react of course
accordingly but I don't know if you this
is somewhat easier to play for black
even because you you have your defenses
schema think pretty much mapped out the
queen is on the edge you will centralize
your rooks and what exactly is about
going to do I think McAuliffe played it
a good at first or well at first plate f
gaining space and also you could have
played me five need to look at that I
think what's important after ye five
that black should just play the night to
d5 you shouldn't do that I'd allow the
cap JM this looks somewhat murky you
don't want your king weakened like that
just 95 seems better after night to g6
let can just play rook f7 and then maybe
the right moment play night to f8
exchanging the somewhat annoying PCM on
g6 yeah f force plate I think this is
fine and root d8 centralizing the rook
yeah I note that Knight g4 attacking the
bishop is not leading to too much white
can just retreat it to see one and maybe
kick the the night on edge with Bishop a
three or poetry it's a bit of a lone
warrior here on g4 it's not supported or
connected to any other piece rook t8 is
some good centralizing move and now
nevertheless h3 was played to to cover
g4 okay Luke f7 yeah this is also fine
it prepares 9 f8 if necessary maybe the
root can double on the default yeah and
now the next couple of moves I think are
very very crucial mamedyarov now played
the move look to d6 after that yeah it's
very tricky to analyze the position as
there are there are various
possibilities I mean White's
compensation in a way lies in the fact
that he's got four against three on the
on the kingside so yes I
yes with pushing those pawns forward
gaining space and ultimately getting an
attack against the king but it's not so
easy to do really 22 time this advanced
correctly um Black has four against two
here and the queenside his majority is
very strong four against two but at the
moment he cannot really move it the
question is however what exactly should
I play this rook t6 move on does have
some drawbacks it it can easily be
changed on the sixes one drawback I'm
not quite sure though what why it should
play it's it's it's really very tricky
one possibility is maybe even g4 i'm
really not i'm really not sold on that
let's say five night f5 this kind of
ideas can be considered takes however
there is queenie fire for example this
is not really a this does not really too
much or is it a night b7 and rook moves
yeah this is stranded piece it's very
tough i mean what i know is that group d
6 is probably not helping so much but
it's difficult to give white advice yes
just a very very difficult position to
play computer IM should just move like
rookie one for example but this does not
look very human well anyway he played
rock d6 after which calls and replied 'i
five it seems that here also 9 f8 was a
good good way to play which is somewhat
similar to them to the game and I think
the reason why he rejected the night of
eight is probably the capture here after
that however black has a strong move but
this is a very unusual
and very unlikely to to to consider by
human play however how strong I have a
the player might be there is g 5 p.m.
which is the computers point and yeah I
know it looks totally crazy what is the
idea yeah that is if the night moves
back there is he for hanging so if i go
back here I can play something like that
and black is an excellent shape it's a
tactical a tactical justification as as
it is so so often a very strange
continuation but it was very interesting
for black to to try cousin played a more
human fashion he played efile not a bad
move at all but it's possible that at
least them from him from a perfectionist
point of view supported by by an
analysis engine that night of 8 was more
precise um however after a five one very
important thing is that the next move is
very very crucial it seems that if you
analyze this position a bit with with
the help of a computer that right only
has one move absolutely just one move
that keeps the game going in a way yeah
why is it so critical already formed for
white yeah it's the problem is this is
not doing so much the d6 said the d6
rook and black is intending to take on
f4 and take on e4 it's got quite a
substantial attacking force already on
this on this central porn and weakness
and white must react to that in a way
you cannot just just ignore it let's say
you play Knight f5 for example black
will take and take care and we'll win
the game it's just like that
it's super important central porn and
white is totally falling apart so you
need to react to that in some way
Mammadyarov played the move f5 and it
turns out that this is yeah probably
losing already I think after that he is
beyond salvation at least that I didn't
find anything and the computer is also
very very pessimistic after that after
this it turns out that the only playable
move it seems to me is rupee one this
does make some sense it's not like it's
a totally computer ish move the idea is
simply that if black takes now Bishop
takes that now you have sufficient cover
for your evo weakness and it takes if f4
is not even a good move really because
night f5 will be will be a very strong
later even after g5 not f5 is very
strong with night h6 and the capture
coming yeah here this is some very
tricky position for black I don't think
black really should take on F form it's
also not necessary really because rookie
one is a good move in terms of
protecting e4 but it's not threatening
anything probably black should play em
you know some small movie very tricky to
analyze this position maybe Roxy aid or
something like that this might allow
Roxy six yeah and now probably right
we'll play em further strengthening
moved maybe Bishop c1 or something and
yeah well then it continues it's just
very complicated black as a pawn up and
probably reasonably satisfied but it's
not an easy win or anything in the game
just to compare things fi was played and
our cars and when droop to evade and we
now see the big problem of whites
position
after f5 there is no dynamism anymore
the pawns here are blockaded and cannot
push forward and the real issue is that
the pony form is really terribly weak
and how despite them protected on e4 and
also what is the night doing on edge
form if you want to return it to the
game I have three you just give a ready
for ya it's impossible to activate and
in concrete terms after 9 f8 from what
exactly is your moose if white for
example takes on the eight just to show
it and grabs on c5 there is something
like root is seven coming brooke may be
entering here and very important idea
Queen to a eight increasing the pressure
on the e4 pawn and I think white is
probably losing the porn quite short
order very difficult to compare how this
is going to be protected yeah in the
gaming it didn't take we played the
Bishop c5 there also was rookie one that
could be considered after that black can
go look ft seven not the only move but a
good one Bishop c5 is not good this is a
very very annoying pin so probably there
will be those kind of kind of traits and
the whole problem at the end of all
those lines is that we form is going to
be doomed various ways to do that let's
say something like that and then queen
a8 will win the for porn ultimately
young the plate Bishop takes d5 after
that capture and rube d7 of course the
rook is strong on the D file it can
maybe invade on d3 and the next move
might be queen 8 to get to the e4 pawn
on if white retreats let's say here
there is this strong move
now this is not this arrow aiming for g5
with the night and then we have a very
funny picture with all minor pieces
attacking the weakness only four and
this is not in any way defensible yeah
well this was played the capture cars
just recaptured yeah and now what is
White's move it's really a bit bit of a
problem you can never really move the
night then back if you go to g6 for
example yeah with the winner of a temple
then check this is happening of course
and let's say King edge too yeah ruby
three coming attending queen here and he
for now is hanging so what do you want
there is just this move and it's a it's
just just just tired of white f5 was
really a really big mistake now what has
absolutely no play he went rook g1
Chatwin c5 check king edge too yeah and
here there's only one move that needs to
be found him Bishop cake c4 and this is
what counts plate and after that
Mammadyarov resigned the game so win for
the world champion a very very important
win of course after two losses in a row
he managed to bounce back with the
winner very good sign for him for his
fans of course after those two not very
good-looking losses I mean okay losses
are hardly ever very great but
they were really not really good game so
good a good term a good sign for cars
and that he managed to bounce back with
a win yeah in the concrete position here
why did mommy gerroff resign yeah okay
well be sure before you need to play and
then there is this intermediate movie on
d1 and night eggs yeah now there is this
big threat Queen f2 black as a pawn up
and white simply does not have a move we
can play something like that defensive
moves and now the only thing that you
need to be aware of is that something
like that which looks nice at first it's
not working check but blundering a piece
can play something like that first and
then just slowly realizing a blacks
advantage here is even something like
that there's an e porn oops this was bad
thick there is an e porn that you can in
use and also potentially you have before
at some point to to free the C porn
before another person on the queenside
so I'm rather convincing win here with
black while mamedyarov really am yeah
I'm not sure about the opening choice in
heaps it looks like he somewhat stumbled
into this type of position and of course
he he got some practical chances out of
it but it's sort of felt like white
needed to be very very precise and at
the end after a five-year this f5 move
really AM was a big problem he played
this rather quickly as we see here and
it seems to almost lose the game it was
hard to figure out maybe in the game how
bad it was but still after that there is
not much to hope for a rupee one was
still quite a playable like quite a
playable position okay I hope you enjoy
to the camera cheer for around six I'll
be back tomorrow so
seven coverage note that this will have
the game Nakamura with wide against
Carlton and considering the history of
those players right I cannot remember a
game between the two that was in any way
dull or uninteresting so we can look
forward to that the car was up he wants
his first win against the world champion
and this is of course also a chance for
cards maybe to get in yet another win to
make it total roller coaster fee okay
looking forward to that okay thanks for
watching